so how did it come to be that your
finger became injured
there was at one point where I
I'd stayed in one of the
you know I'm sitting on a bathroom floor
locked she's banging away banging away
screaming blah blah blah and then
suddenly she stopped and I could hear
her walk away and I got I left the
place the the room that I was hiding in
or not hiding locked myself into
and I went downstairs in the house there
was downstairs in the house
as soon as you walk in the house you can
go upstairs or downstairs downstairs
there was a sort of a wreck wreck area
pool table and such
and uh and there was a
bar
and uh I was
um I was a mess I was a wreck I was
shaking and I I just didn't understand
why
all this was happening
so
I went behind the bar
I grabbed a bottle of vodka that was
there and a shot glass
and sat at the bar she was nowhere
around
and I
poured myself
two or three stiff shots of of the vodka
first taste of alcohol it had in a long
time and um
then she came down
to the bar and found me there
and of course started screaming oh
you're drinking again yeah the monster
and all that
um
so she reached she she walked up to me
and reached and grabbed the
bottle of vodka
and then just uh kind of stood back and
then
hurled it at me
and and it it uh
it just went
right past my head and smashed
behind me
uh
so
I stood up
and I walked behind the bar
and there was a larger bottle of vodka
the kind with the handle you know on it
I grabbed that and I went and I sat in
my seat again
I opened the bottle and I poured myself
a shot
drank it
Missouri was
flinging insults left right and center
and
she then grabbed that bottle
and uh
and through that
me
um and the way that the
the way that the bar was situated
and we're a Miss herb was
so if if
I could show you so if
this is the bar
was
and
the bottles
if this was the bar and I'm assuming
here like this she would rather follow
and she would go there she went there
and so I
was leaning like this in the chair
looking at her first bottle went
then got the other bottle shot
takes the second bottle which was the
larger one
I'm in this position again
and my my hand is on the edge of the
the bar like like that you know leaning
over the fingers
like that and uh
she threw the large bottle
and it made contact
and shattered
everywhere
and
I honestly didn't I didn't feel the pain
at first at all I felt no pain
whatsoever
when I felt was
um
I felt Heat
I felt heat and I felt
as if something were dripping down my
hand you know
um and then I
looked down and
realized that the the tip of my finger
had been
severed
and
I was looking directly at
my bones
sticking out
and uh for the
the
meaty portion of your the inside of your
finger the
um
and it was blood was just uh pouring
out
and at that point
I I I I think that I went into some sort
of
I I don't know what a nervous breakdown
feels like
but that's probably the closest that
I've ever been I didn't
nothing made sense
and I knew in my mind and in my heart
this is this is not life
this is not life
no one should have to go through this
which finger was was caught Mr Depp
um it's the middle
it's a funny looking one it's the middle
finger
here you can see the
well you can see all the sort of
that they from the
initial wound this this
all these bones up here were crushed
and it looked like a it looked like
Vesuvius you know and um
so this this
part of my finger now is so that because
of
not having use of the tip here this is
um
basically uh arthritis that kicks into
the joint once that once that
upper part of the finger is mangled
so is that the right middle finger right
middle yes and is that your dominant
hand
uh yes it is yes
Mr Deb after
misheard through the vodka bottle at you
and severed your finger
um
what if anything did she say when she
saw the injury
I don't recall anything but just uh
it was almost like white noise it's just
someone yelling just it was just a high
pitched
constant
attack of insults of it was just
jumbled words to me in a very high
frequency and I I I I I was in a bit of
shock you know
if I'd like to show you a picture if we
could please pull up plaintiff's exhibit
145.
foreign
what is this a picture of
that is um
that's me in the emergency room
I see
I see a detail that I forgot I'd
forgotten
which is the
Missouri that pulled
taking my cigarette from
the ashtray and uh
stomped it out in my
face here did you mark on the screen
where you see that
um
it's right
above that Green Dot
and do you know who took that this
picture
I do not know
uh can we please publish this to the
jury do you want internet evidence yes
please any objection
all right 145 and evidence you can
publish to the jury
and so Mr adapt now that the jury can
see the photograph can you again explain
what that Green Dot is identifying
um just above the
well
just
above the green the Green Dot
is a
a a wound uh from
misheard
taking my cigarette
and and um
this is after the finger had
gone away
um and she stubbed it out in my in in my
face and on my cheek
please pull up plaintiff's exhibit 343
and for the record this is an audio
recording and we it's um quite lengthy
so we intend to play certain portions of
it
and it's not to get you mad it's not
it's just to get out of a bad situation
while it's happening before it gets
worse in Australia when we had the big
fight where I lost the tip of my finger
at least
five bathrooms and two bedrooms I went
to
two two two avoid talking to me
to escape the fight you don't escape the
fight you escape the solution you escape
the solution you escape figuring it out
we cannot work it out if you run away to
the bathroom every time listen to me
listen to me
the boxer can't go 12 rounds without a
minute break I'm not not giving you a
minute break you do it at minute three
at the beginning of an argument
there are rounds man and when it gets
too hairy the refs puts them apart or
whatever but I'm all I'm saying is
you you you can't have a solution if
the argument just keeps mounting and
mounting and mounting and mounting I go
to the into the bathroom and sit on the
floor Bam Bam Bam here you come
I come out fight fight fight fight crazy
escalated I go split again I go to
another bathroom or a bedroom or
something knock knock bang bang you kept
coming to get me
[Music]
dude I'm not the one who throws
pots and there's a difference
that's different that's what one does
not negate the other that's irrelevant
it's a complete non-sequitur just
because I've thrown pots and pans does
not mean that you come and knock on the
door just because there are vases does
not mean that you come and knock on the
door really I should just let you throw
I'm not saying that you're saying that
you're putting words in my mouth and
then making non-sequiturs giving you a
situation no you're trying to justify
how you don't or do come to the door
based on whether I throw positive hand
it's irrelevant I'm justifying how you
you you seem to think that there's this
cowardice in me that runs away and I
don't fight for you
and you're justifying that by saying I
throw pots and pans okay cool let's talk
about everything you do wrong I'm not
the one who
I said to Travis I said no I said to you
hey tell Travis we'll just happen oh you
tell me to do it you told me to he said
go do that I said no tell them what
you're saying and I lied and that you
punched me
you figured it off and you said
and I watched you lie and then I didn't
punch you by the way you I'm sorry that
I didn't uh uh hit you across the face
in a proper slot but I was hitting you
it was not punching you babe you're not
punched don't tell me what it feels like
to be punched you know even a lot of
fights been around a long time I don't
know yeah
you didn't get punched you got hit I'm
sorry I hit you like this but I did not
punch you I did not deck you I was
hitting you I don't know what the
promotion of my actual hand was but
you're fine I did not hurt you I did not
punch you I was hitting you how what am
I supposed to do do this I'm not sitting
here bitching about it am I you are
that's the difference between me and you
your baby
physical fights
I did start a physical fight
yes you did so you did the right thing
the big thing the you know what you are
admirable
Mr dab could you please explain to the
jury what they just heard on those audio
recordings
um
thank you
what what was just played on the audio
recordings
was um
very much the tone
and the
aggression and the
attitude
um and the
need
for a fight
from his hurt
that was
I don't know if that was some
need for attention but um
I don't it that that was that was a
sound
that I've gotten you very used to
the the squabbling the
the
you know the the raising of the voice to
to
essentially
excommunicate anything that I had to say
about the situation